[Music]
hey guys we finally received our first
game of turn season a trailer
and after breaking it down it's time for
theories the most mysterious part of the
trailer is this shot of tyrion
notice how there's no snow around him
and yet at the end of season 7 there's
snow everywhere from winterfell to
king's landing
the entire trailer mostly includes
scenes from the first three episodes but
this shot right here might be the only
shot from the game turns finale after
the night king's been defeated
is he confirming some leaks regarding
his fade that we've had for a few months
now one would wonder
but his look does imply that things are
not going very well for himself at this
point
and right after that we have drug on
burning someone alive could it someone
be tyrion who is sentenced to death
some of you may or may not know that all
the info about this trailer has been
leaked a few days before the trailer was
even released
we know exact day an hour it would be
released as well as all the key scenes
it would feature
it was leaked by freaky doctor who also
leaked the entire season 7.
regarding this final season 8 beside
leaking trailer info that turned out to
be 100
true he also leaked tyrion's fate and
death a few months ago
and the trailer seems to be supporting
his claim as if he doesn't already have
high credibility
however if you don't want such a huge
event to be spoiled to you you should
close this video
anyways freaky doctor finally got some
info regarding the final season a few
months ago and he shared it
it's about the final plot vest of the
series that will take place in the
season 8 finale
it's about tyrion lannister who's
intelligence humor and wit made him
fan's favorite character
however he will apparently end as a
traitor and will face a trial of the
dragon pit for that which will result in
his death
tyrion will be on trial for betraying
danny over his family cersei lannister
and not only because of that but because
he also burned down king's landing to
the ground
in details freaky doctor says that
before trial tyrion is taking a walk
with jon and davos in king's landing
this is before trial and it's the
aftermath of the destruction of the city
there are dead bodies everywhere a lot
of innocent people the camera pans to
tirion
showing him horrified thinking to
himself what have i done
this actually matches with leaked photos
in which we seeking's laning set
completely destroyed and burned down
tyrion is responsible for the burning of
king's landing and according to the
league there were not even whites or
white walkers inside the city bowls
when this burning took place why did he
do it
it says that tyrion's main and only
objective was to kill the people of
king's landing
all 1 million of them tyrion's objective
was to avoid the steady population from
turning into whites
tyrion probably thought the night king
would end up taking the capital so he
decided to burn it
and its 1 million population in order to
prevent the night king from creating a
huge army
that would probably be hard to defeat at
that point many will die including some
main characters
who we know will certainly survive are
the characters who are being on tyrion's
trial
branson sayara robin sambry and grave
worm davos
and two mysterious characters out of
those not present on the trial miss
sandee john and dany are also alive at
this point
but are somewhere else john's even taken
a walk with tyrion earlier in this
episode
among the survivors caesar stark will
also attend the trial
but she almost met her end during the
destruction arya's caught in the fire of
king's landing but manages to escape
survive
daetherian confessed his guilt while
taking a walk with john and davos across
the maulish capital
did the horrified looked tearing head
while overlooking all the lifeless
bodies so if all the innocent people
gave him away
its brain and his three-eyed raven
skills that's going to be an end for
tyrion
the source says that bran has a talk
with sansa bren is the one who tells of
tyrion's betrayal to others
tyrion will then be imprisoned and put
under a trial how i see it happening is
john and davos showing tyrion all the
lifeless bodies of hundreds of thousands
of innocent people
basically showing him what he has done
and then at the end of the road they
revealed to him they know it's him who
caused it
imprisoning him and locking him down
however nor
jon nor dany will decide his fate as
they are not judges of the trial
they won't even attend it in the charge
of our trial is sir davos seaward he is
the judge accompanied with total starks
sansa are yambran stark they're also
simultarily robin and rayne briennotar
tiara grey vormin two new characters
one of them burying a golden armor who
is either someone from dorne or the
golden company commander
the other wears green clothes possibly
being holland reed
tyrion is a traitor and is being judged
in the game of turns finale
he has betrayed dany and has sided with
his family but how is it possible one
would ask
well actually it's all been happening
before arise as most of us would claim
tyrion has done everything he could to
aid in the rise of danny targaryen
the queen he believes can bring
stability to westeros
her cause is the one he believes in he's
trying to keep her from making rash
violent decisions
so that she can be seen as a ruler the
realm needs but has he truly been
fighting for the best of dany
has he really been making decisions that
will bring danny one step closer towards
the throne
just the opposite turn has been fighting
for house lannister throughout the
entire season 7 and we've all witnessed
it
tyrion's been preventing house lannister
from falling during the entire past
season
because of tyrion and his warplanes
denny's lost most of her allies
and her strength has drastically
decreased tyrion's plans also resulted
with the food and gold being unprotected
and basically led for cersei to take it
which she did
throughout his meeting with search site
tier and even confess that he is the one
preventing house lannister from falling
tyrion and cersei made a deal on their
meeting exactly when the camera cut away
and it's tyrion who told cersei to
promise jon and danny to help them in
the wars to come
tyrion realized cersei is pregnant and
he is probably working to put atlantis
from the throne
ensuring his house is future even though
cersei will have a miscarriage in the
season a premiere
but that's irrelevant how else could you
explain why cersei just the moments ago
refused to help them in the war against
the dead
only to a be later after her meeting
with tyrion come back at the dragon pit
and promise dany to aid them
even though she will not why would she
change her mind all of a sudden
terry knew cersei was not going to go
north as she said it herself to all of
them a bit earlier
and so he told her to lie about it for
now tyrion told her to make a false
promise of supporting them with the
troops
and that they buy more time to improve
her armies also how likely is that
tyrion loyal to dany would not see
through cersei's lies
tyrion said three people and their
intentions as easily as reads books
which has been proven right multiple
times through the series
but he fails to read through cersei he
actually fails to read the search's
intention and he believes cersei will
send help
tirion and cersei most likely made a
deal on their meeting exactly when the
camera cut away
and it's tyrion who told cersei to agree
with jon and dany and to promise them
the help in the wars to come
having earlier in the same episode
sinterian emphasized the value of a good
lie to jon snow
it's reasonable to believe he'd stress
this to his sister behind closed doors
tyrion had a deal with cersei he knew
she was not going to go north
and he told her to lie about it even the
scene in which cersei reveals her true
intention to jaime could be seen as a
proof that tyrion has already betrayed
dany
cersei says to jaime you were always the
dumbest lannister this is in reference
to him falling for a lie
but tyrion was also there and is also
lannister if he fell for a lie as well
it would be an odd phrase for her to use
i feel like her attitude then phrasing
implies that tyrion was in on the lie
basically tyrion works for the best of
his family for cersei but at the same
time not for the best of the living
anyways back to the trial bran stark
will use his green side powers during
this trial and take us back to the first
season
bramble recalls something tyrion said to
his mother kathleen stark in the first
season
it's tyrion's statement about his family
there's another thing we know
tyrion will say they deserve it implying
that the people of king's landing
deserve to die
tyrion is full of anger the most
dramatic moment of the trial will be
tyrion falling on his knees in the
middle of the speech dragged down by his
actions
he also will not be able to ask for a
trial by combat
freaky doctor doesn't know how tyrion
will be executed because unlike the
trial
his death was not filmed in seville but
in the studio my guess is drogon will do
it and here we see it
he also mentions that there will not be
much of a snow at the dragon pit as most
of it already melted down at this point
of the season
meaning the winter is most likely over
by the time tyrion is being under trial
and it perfectly matches with a shot
from the trailer as well
this tyrion's betrayal might have even
been foretold in the prophecy in books
in george r.r martin novels dany hears
the prophecy in the house of the undying
the leads are to believe she'll face
three key betrayals
the prophecy says three treasons fill
you know one's for blood then once for
gold and one's for love
while this exact prophecy never made it
into the show the betrayal certainly did
in season one miriam mazdur killed her
unborn son to save jogo's life
this is a treason for blood since
miriam's door betrayed her in revenge
for the attack on her village
and the actual ritual only returns drogo
to a vegetative state
while causing her son to die in her boom
jarrah betrayed danny for gold as he
spied on dany for king robert
hired by varys in exchange for gold the
only one treason left is the one for
love and that would be tyrion
marking the biggest plot fist of the
series beside dany's love for tyrion
that fulfills that part of the prophecy
danny was also warned in the novel of
dancing dragons
not to trust tyrion with this prophecy
soon comes the pale mayor
and after her the others kraken and dark
flame lion and griffin
the sun's sun and the mummer's dragon
trust none of them
remember the undying beware the perfumed
seneschal
lion the house lanes are sigil is widely
accepted to be tyrion lannister
all these glows and hints along with the
most reliable source releasing season at
least that claim that tyrion is going to
be in the season finale under trial for
his treason
makes this huge plot fest almost a
certain thing especially now the trailer
has been released a few shots seem to be
confirming it
tyrion has survived two trials thus far
but this the third one seems to be an
end for him
if true i honestly won't feel bad for
tyrion but i'll feel bad for jaime who
saved the city from the mad king and
will possibly save it from cersei as
well during the final season
only to see its sibling tyrion burning
everything and everyone down
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our channel and i hope
to see you in the next one peace
[Music]
you